From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Great.
Okay, so I'm just going to introduce all of us first and then we'll start the interview.
So today is June 22nd, 2013. I'm in Louisville, Kentucky.
This is David Cline speaking from the History Department at Virginia Tech,
also working with the Southern Oral History Program at UNC Chapel Hill.
Recording this interview for the Civil Rights History Project of the National Museum of African American History and Culture,
the Smithsonian and the Library of Congress.
Behind the camera today is John Bishop from UCLA and Media Generation,
and very pleased to be speaking with Walter Tillow today in Louisville.
If you could introduce yourself, tell us where you were born in your age and then we'll start a conversation.
I'm 73 years old. I was born in New York City and raised in the Bronx in New York City.
Okay, and as I said off camera, I like to start with people's childhoods.
And as you can tell us a little bit about your family and if you see any influences from your family or your upbringing,
that may have influenced your work later on.
Well, as I said, I was born in the Bronx, New York City.
My mother worked for the State of New York in the Unemployment Insurance Division.
And my dad was a, had a small business in washing machines, laundromats,
type of, just becoming technology coin operated laundry.
I grew up in a basically middle class lifestyle.
My parents had been radicals members of the Young Communists League in the 1920s,
although the depression and family kind of calmed them down.
You know, they kind of went on to other things.
But that was a background in my growing up, the Cold War.
The execution of Rosenbergs was something that I was 13 at the time.
I remember a discussion in the kitchen between my mom and dad as to whether my mother should go to the funeral.
They were executed on a Friday. The funeral was according to Jewish law.
It had to be buried 24 hours, so the funeral was sanity.
And they eventually decided that my mother shouldn't go.
And so my father insisted on taking me with him.
And so that was a memorable impact on my, and also I had a half of the family that was kind of radical.
The other half was conservative. And so, you know, family arguments through the Cold War.
I kind of was aware of progressive left politics, you know, and Soviet Union, socialism, and so forth.
But your parents radicalism was sort of, it's a little bit removed at that point.
Yeah, they weren't the members. They weren't subscribers.
I had an aunt who was a subscriber. I had another aunt who was a member of Communist Party.
But I didn't know that. And, you know, I knew them as aunts and, you know, as I say, progressive arguments.
For me and my family, it was not, you know, nothing was in family life.
Meetings or something like that. No, it was no.
It was sort of a basic middle class existence, 1950s.
What about race issues in New York at that time when you were growing up? Any impact?
My sister had a friend in school. My folks became friends with her family, her parents, you know, they became socially acquainted.
At that time in New York, there was, I grew up right outside of Parkchester.
Parkchester was the largest development, private development apartments funded by Metropolitan Life.
And it was segregated, although it wasn't officially segregated, they just wouldn't rent the African Americans.
And on the rent control, you had to keep an apartment vacant for one year in order to decontrol it.
So, Metropolitan Life would, somebody would move out of Parkchester, they would keep the apartment vacant for a year, you know, and then it would become decontrolled.
So, there was a housing movement. It wasn't only in Louisville at the time. That's the (Anne and Carl) Bradens origin, you know, same movement.
So, it would change themselves to the door, you know, on these vacant apartments, there was a movement to try and get met life, you know.
So, I was aware of that kind of a movement, but other than that, we didn't participate, you know, it was just my sister's friends, parents lived in Parkchester.
So, we kind of knew, they didn't participate either, but you kind of got reports, you know, there was an incident, you know, people would change themselves to the door in this building, you know, and kind of talk.
You know, that way. But other than that, as I say to Rosenbergs, you know, the Cold War more, I came upon my father, you know, in the garage one day, you know, the thrown out, literally it collected, you know, newspapers, and, you know, he kind of showed me, he was getting rid of it.
And another incident, I had a, my aunt lived in Westchester County, my uncle was an artist and a cartoonist. So, it was a rural, at that time it was rural, rural, upstate New York, you know, and all those and too far from New York City.
And some friends at AIS had given them some books. Actually, they gave them a collection of the works of Lenin because they had to get them out of there. They felt they couldn't keep them in their, in their apartment in New York and people came, you know, this, it was that kind of an atmosphere that Cold War atmosphere was, you know, kind of impinged upon your, your consciousness, you know, whatever.
But, but those are just incidents, you know, looking back, you know, kind of at the time when I was in college, she gave me the 13 volumes, you know, she was.
So, so I mean, I actually got a collected works of Lenin, you know, when I was in college because she had been holding of somebody, they finally said the hell would have, you know, thrown away and rather than thrown away she gave me.
So, yeah.
Okay. Fantastic. So, what, I guess you could tell us a little bit about college and sort of what brought you into the movement.
I don't know if there's one moment or if it was a gradual process.
Well, I went to a Harpur College, which was a state university in New York.
At that time it was, it was in a bunch of quants and huts and converted mansions and endocut in New York.
And now it's a, it's a big graduate center campus and best of, you know, nearby.
When I started it was, it was a school that relied mainly on vets coming back on the G.I. Bill, you know, and 1960 I was a junior and the sitting movement broke out.
And we decided, we had a lot of kids from New York City at the school because it was cheap.
I think tuition at that time was $300 a year and they went on a dorm so you could live off, you know, when I went there, they went on a dorm.
When I finished there, what dorms? But when I went there, they went on a dorm so you had to live off campus.
So, you know, it drew a lot of, you know, people that didn't want to go to city college but wanted to go to, couldn't afford a private school.
So we got to evolve with the picketing Walmart.
We wanted a first, second school to picket, have a sympathy demonstration at the local, not Walmart.
Woolworth, Woolworth Company.
You know, the administration fought as Bentley, you know, and we had this argument with student government and actually we found a clipping that Harvard did it and that was kind of convinced student government that we could do it.
So, you know, so we picket it into the Woolworth and Johnson City, you know, but that was kind of, that was the first, you know, kind of way for that.
Thank you.
That was like, we responded to the times, you know, sitting, moving, broke out, you know, it made perfect sense, you know, segregation.
You know, we had Woolworth, you know, all over the place at that time, they all had countless, lunch, countless and so forth.
So, that was when I was a junior and we went on to some more radical activities that, when I between, in my senior year, we were moved on to the new campus, which we had to live on the campus, you know, and they needed the money.
So, they made everybody on the campus.
So, we had, you know, we got involved there at that time in New York State, at that time nationally, but in New York State they had a one day shelter drill.
It was in the Cold War, you know, afraid the Soviets would win a bomb, nuclear bombs, you had to find the shelter, you know, and so they rang of siren and noon all over the state.
People had to take cover, you know, it was in campus.
So, there were a couple of passivists on, you know, in the school and we heard that they were going to go have a picnic rather than, you know, they're going to go in the woods, you know, it was sort of a rural campus.
So, we said, well, let's just stand outside in the quage, you know, and so we had 50, 60, 70 kids, you know, defied the take cover drill, you know, and stood out there.
The president called hell, you know, he was, you know, we had a dean that had some principal and he stood up for us, but, you know, one thing went to another.
And from there, somebody had an idea, not me.
There was a young Democrats, a young Republicans, we were going to organize a young socialists and we organized it, meaning you got money from a student government.
So, it was an official organization?
You recognize student organization and we invited a comment, well, we invited a social worker person to speak.
Nobody knew, you know, the name would pop up, yeah, you know. And because of us, the air raid drill protest, the president forbid her to speak even harder from the campus.
And the faculty was, because the state paid better in the lower positions, you know, assistant and lecturer, you know, we had a lot of future names, you know,
that took a job out of graduates to pay off loans because the money was better. So, it was in a conscious, you know, where smart faculty, and they kind of took away his power to bar anybody from speaking on campus as a result of that barring that that social worker party candidate.
The next name that came up was a guy named Herbert Aptheker. He was a prominent communist historian, Ph.D. from Columbia. And we had a big battle over him, you know, the American Legion threatened to pick it, you know, the president wanted to bar him, but he couldn't do it.
You know, the question came up, what are you going to charge money and not charge money and to admit it. The result was that place was packed, seven, eight hundred people in the newly opened auditorium, you know, and another impact on me was a particularly effective public speaker.
So, you know, that was sort of my academic career, you know, when I went out to the University of Washington as a graduate student the next year, there was another fight. I wasn't involved in other than to attend his lecture, but he was barred from speaking at the University of Washington.
Same thing, he spoke off campus, you know, and I attended the meeting. And so I had some contact that way, you know, with progressive ideas, radical ideas, in some case, at the University of Washington, actually.
There was some young communists that organized that meeting and I got to know them. But, and Cornell. So that was, I went to University of Washington as a graduate student, 61, 62.
What were you studying?
Economic history. And then I went back to Cornell, 62, 63 as a graduate student. At Cornell, we had sort of a kind of a breakfast.
You know, a group of us graduate students, undergraduates, we'd meet every morning for breakfast in the student activity center. I forget what it was called.
There was a big major strike of the newspapers in New York City. It was a strike over technology. The printers were striking to bar, you know, cold type technology.
It was, it was a line of type days and, you know, they wanted to go to cold type, what eventually. And it was a long strike. And, you know, in a place like Cornell, the New York Times not being, you know, everybody was starving.
So somebody had a bright idea that we could, we could read various, and in deference to the New York Times, since it was, you know, a major issue for the whole industry.
Other newspapers of Washington Post, they wouldn't send in copies.
The areas were at a New York Times. So, as I say, people were starving, you know. So somebody had a bright idea if we subscribed to a variety of, or read them in the library and came in once a week with clippings of, you know, then we would reproduce them and put them up around campus.
So, somehow I got to read the Baltimore-African-American. That was my choice. And we would bring any articles. Somebody would paste them up and duplicate it. And then we would post it up around the campus.
And the annual SNCC convention, the Easter meeting came up in Afro-American. It was in April of 1963. So, a couple of us decided to go.
And I went, you know, a car loan of us went, and that's where I met Anne Braden. And that's how I got involved. You know, that's the story of how I got involved.
But you had read about it and just gotten the car and went. Well, we know it was an announcement. You know, they covered the story about SNCC's annual Easter conference.
At that time, they had founded 1960. So, this is like the third, you know, third Easter conference of the Student of Bioanca Women Committee. So...
And where was it, Helen?
And it was held in Gammon Theological Seminary in Atlanta.
And the Old Gammond, you know, the Old Theological Seminary.
So...
It became inter-denominational.
Right, right.
So, we were looking. No, we had an idea about the summer... You know, going south for the summer. A couple of us.
And the only person that would talk with us seriously and had an idea was Anne.
She suggested that Fayette County, Tennessee, you know, the movement there needed some people.
So, three of us, you know, Bunny Haney + Charlie Haney, he was a mathematics, his wife, bunny, and their infant baby, you know, a month old.
A couple of months old, and they went down to myself, went to Fayette County, Tennessee for that summer of 1963.
We must have got there, May, June.
Stayed through to March on Washington.
In other words, and Fayette County was a...
It was a place where in the 1930s, the federal government had tried an experiment in terms of increasing black land ownership.
There was a WPA or, I don't know, was WPA.
But it was some project to increase black ownership of land.
Eleanor Roosevelt, you know, was involved.
So, there was a county that was probably nine... Two counties there, just east of Memphis Shelby County.
They sit right on the Mississippi board.
They were like an extension of the Delta, Fayette and Haywood County.
But they had... While they were 90% African-American, they had a high percentage of black land owned their own land, you know, in the county.
Although they had a sharecropping system for whites.
And there was a case, a criminal case where a preacher was charged with murder and he fled the county.
And he had come back. This is before my...
And the lawyers that defended him, they asked every perspective juror, do they have any problem with African-Americans voting?
Because he couldn't serve on a jury unless you're on a voting rolls in those days.
So, of course, everybody answered, no, they had no problem.
So, there were a number of Vets, Korean War Vets, were two Vets that, you know, had attended the trial because of the prominence of the minister.
And they heard everybody say, well, we don't object to African-Americans voting.
So, they went out to try and erole African-Americans.
And that's the origin of the movement that whites retaliated by expelling sharecroppers from the land.
Because they were African-Americans that owned their own farms.
They set up tents on Black-owned land to house sharecroppers that had been expelled.
And there was a movement guy, a minister, and since then I had Marcheka McCracken, and there was some sort of a community church.
I think it was called a community church.
Got involved, and the (Anne and Carl) Bradens got involved.
And there was a big movement in Chicago to support tent city.
It became tent city.
And it so happens that they were sending food and clothes because the winner was chilly.
Who was organizing on the ground, the core local organizing?
I don't know who was in that time, it was before my day, there were night-ride people who would ride by and shoot into the tents.
It got some national publicity at the time in the 50s.
But the movement in Chicago, you know, there were unions, a guy named Jesse Prosten, and from the pack-and-house workers, his wife, and some others.
They hired somebody to kind of coordinate between Chicago and the whole movement.
And that guy, if they hired, was James (Jim) Forman.
And became executive director of SNCC.
So when I got to Fayette County,
I had no...
Foreman was in Atlanta as the executive director of SNCC.
But had been in...
But he had this role, you know, as coordinated down and back, you know, with supplies.
And as I say, had national attention.
There were other, you know, there were efforts to self-help projects.
You know, there was an effort to set up a making leather book bags.
Or, you know, in Haywood County, I think, you know, there was some project to kind of build homes for these people on land that was purchased.
Because we stayed in an uncompleted home.
I mean, I did. I think the Haneys, with the baby, they stayed with some family.
But I stayed in a vacant house interior just no walls, you know, framed, but no walls, no plumbing.
You know, I just were able to sleep there.
But we took a trip to Atlanta in the middle of the summer.
That's where I met Forman,
And he had this affection for Fayette County because of his involvement there.
So he kind of took an interest.
And while I was there, you know, there were a couple of teenagers, two or three teenagers that were in hot water.
The police were looking for them in South Georgia, in Albany.
And so, Charles Sherrod wanted to get them out of, so they sent them back.
They asked if I could keep them in Fayette County.
So they came back with me and they spent the summer.
And that was a summer of March in Washington.
So there was, you know, several buses from Fayette and Haywood County went to the March.
Went to the March.
A local people.
And I went back from the March to Atlanta, you know, (Jim) (Jim) Forman an indicator.
Did you go to the March?
Yes, I was.
Yeah, so you went.
And did you go with these?
No, I didn't.
I don't remember the circumstances, but I didn't go with the buses that went, you know.
I may have gone home, you know, back to New York first, or, I don't know what the Haneys did.
It may have been that the three of us did something.
But I went back from the March to Atlanta.
And that's when I started to work for SNCC, you know.
Pause, just.
Okay, back to the...
Okay, got it.
I know I'm tethered.
Tell me when you're ready.
Great.
So, but before you went down to Atlanta to work with SNCC, the SNCC office there,
the project in Fayette County was that...
Was that a SNCC project?
No, it wasn't a SNCC project.
Okay.
As I say, Anne Braden, they had covered SCEF, it covered the...
The Brains were friends with McCracken and Cincinnati.
Carl Braden, you know, when he was a black ball by the Courier Journal, I think he worked for the Enquirer,
One of the newspapers in Cincinnati, you know.
So they knew McCracken.
So it was just a matter of they knew somebody was, you know, typical movement.
They thought somebody, you know, we got there, we were told to go to this white guy.
He was a farmer, a red friend.
He was friendly with the African Americans.
He tried to run for sheriff, you know, and they didn't make it, you know.
But so we spent a couple nights with him, but we couldn't stay there because of what we were...
We did voter registration primarily.
And that was dangerous for him, David?
Yeah, it was dangerous for him to...
And also destructive of his political, you know, intentions.
In those days, you courted the black vote privately, you know.
So we moved over and we did voter registration work, you know.
Going out every day.
Yeah, trying to talk in churches and trying to take people down and...
And having back up.
Well, it didn't go very far, you know.
I got jumped once coming back from downtown.
And the other thing we did something with the youngsters.
I told you we took a bunch of swimming in Memphis in a black YMCA or YWC.
I forget which one it was.
You know, kids had never been swimming.
So they didn't have bathing suits, so bunny.
We were in touch with the guys back in Cornell.
And they rounded up donated bathing suits, you know.
Women's and men, girls and boys.
And we had enough suits to take three or four car loads, you know, to swim.
So we did stuff like that, you know, kind of...
You go around to speak.
At that time we also had an incident where McFarran, the head of the movement there was a guy named John McFerren.
He had a gas station grocery store, small, you know.
And he had been subject, you know, to boycotts, you know, couldn't buy gas, you know, and so forth.
And so he was an effective guy, you know.
And as I say, the core of the leadership were black farmers that own their own land.
You know, it wasn't preaches, you know.
They were a little bit different, you know, kind of...
So some woman accused them of rape.
You know, African American woman.
I have it a bit of white woman.
And so it became a family prop.
You know, we spent a lot of time, you know, kind of educating him and his wife.
She was pregnant at the time, you know, herself.
And, you know, what kind of how things work, you know, what have you.
So we did a variety of those kinds of things.
And it was a completely...
It had been a big movement at the time of Tent City.
You know, there were no more tents, as I say, some movement people.
I think maybe the community church or others were building houses slowly,
because the Haney State and the House that had been given to a woman who had been evicted.
So it was a little bit, you know, an extra bedroom and indoor plumbing, you know,
you know, whatever.
I stayed in the house that was incomplete, you know, no interior.
That was being built, for example.
Yeah, but it was being built, yeah.
You weren't the only two.
So the movement had kind of died down.
So it was a matter of registration.
We had a couple of days, you know, trying to get a lot of people to go down to register.
And it was a process in Tennessee.
You know, you had to read the Constitution, or whatever the clerk wanted you to read.
You know, I mean, it was...
And it was the violence.
There was no violence at the courthouse.
But it was just a dragged-out procedure, you know.
You know, it's gonna ask the clerks made did they make that difficult?
Yeah, no, it was like a two hour three hour it could be any make each individual you know they go in there and
and
You know reading was was a so if you couldn't read, you know, yeah difficulty reading, you know
Yet all these kind of problems so it was slow moving right they towarded it by right by slow moving and
And did you encounter resistance from African Americans that you were trying to encourage to
You know
Well, you know, people don't go, you know that's you know only the brave go those that you know
So in that sense where there's no resistance, you know, there was no opposition, you know in a sense that
Don't do it. You know, we can't do it, but they just didn't go so you got who wanted to go, you know
You could you get to go after minister was sympathetic right you'd get some people you know
You're spoken as church if you let you speak in a church you could get some
Some people to go and and and then you have to take them down or we as I say we had one of two days
I think we had a march around a courthouse square. We organized, you know and in
In some of them that was a cap, you know the county seat
Mm-hmm some built on a seat and what was the white resistance or white response?
well
You know, you don't encounter too much because you're in a black community exclusive a version
So let's say I was I was driving back from some of the once, you know
It wasn't that far to McFerrent store. I was staying near the store, you know
and you know I got
Way laid by I was alone in the car, you know, so somebody in front of me stopped on a road came back and try to beat me up
You know what I what have you so but other than that and how it you know wasn't prevalent, you know
I mean it wasn't like can you tell me a little bit more about that?
experience
You try to get away. Yeah
That's best you can you know, I was just one on one so you know
I was a getaway. It wasn't like a gang, you know, it had been a gang. I would have been a big trouble
But it was just one guy, you know, you know, it's sort of like a road rage, you know
I mean it wasn't like an organ, I'm sure there were organized clan members, but you know and Fayette County the worst had been
you know
seen in the tent city, you know, they were beatings and shootings and you know drive by shootings into the tents, you know back
when the tent city so
this was sort of like the
Continuation and it wasn't as dramatic as I say the tents were gone
You know housing had been replaced and McFerrent had had I mean
Redfearn, the white guy had run once or twice for sheriff
Okay, so there's already been a little bit. So you know, he was courting, you know, the word would go around, you know
You know vote from McFerrent, you know, those that could vote, you know, what have you so as I say
but it was it was like 85 and 90% African American that the population, you know in both counties, Fayette and Haywood
You know, that sort of thing so
Let's still somehow the we're not somehow, but it's pretty obvious when someone comes in from out of town
People knew who you were right there were three of us came, you know, and I say they hadn't been anybody
In a while, you know, you know, you know, what have you because the thing it kind of peed it out as they say there was
There was some self-help project in Haywood County the next county over to make these leather book bags and sell them by mail
You know, but it wasn't going anywhere and uh, so things that kind of uh, you know slow down. So three new people show up
You know, it starts it all over you, right?
so
Hmm, okay, so from there to Atlanta
So I got to Atlanta and uh
I ended up working with Julian Bond in what was the community called communications office
uh
In those days we would put out a news release or a packet of news releases
every
three days
So three times a week
You know, you could send five pieces of paper for a stamp one stamp first-class mail
I think called braiding that given Julian a press list, you know
sold the African-American press and
White left press and liberal pray, you know, so we would do these really about incidents
you know and uh
Somebody got beat up or you know, what have you and uh and uh
some incident and
We would write letters for John Lewis, you know, outrage letters that we could quote in the release, you know mean
condemning the justice department for enacting on the FBI, you know, I mean all we would kind of write a letter
for John to send that would have a
Quote that we could pull out and use in the press release about
You know, so and and uh, you know, Julian was like a one of the early
Scientific PR guy, you know kind of understood the PR, you know, and what have you and he had worked for
The length of voice he'd started his career or some black
Yeah, you know upstart newspaper in the in the lantern and
and sensationalism, you know, was the order today, you know and
So uh, we were looking for those things and we did some
You know, we found uh
At the at the time uh, Byron De La Beckwith was being tried for the murder of Medgar Evers
The federal government was buying land from him
To build a post office in Greenwood, you know, we found
We were clipping. We had a clipping service. So
We made a stink over that, you know, and uh
We also had a WATS line. We were one of first
It's an eight hundred line. I don't know if you know
So technology is so uh, there were
People were coming to Jackson or to some play, you know, it was a segregated audience
So there was supposed to be bonanza. I don't know if you remember bonanza was a big TV wasn't TV show, you know
Lorne Greene and and it's and they were they had some sort of
of a
Side business doing these shows, you know, the bonanza cast or some of them and whatever they did
Never sort of shows that it was booked to be in Jackson and uh, we contacted them on a watch
We tracked them down the city before
That's what we would call them
You know, we try and get from our agent what the tour was
And so we we would reach them before they got
the Jackson and uh and actually we got the bonanza people to cancel
They wouldn't they wouldn't appear before a segregated audience
blacks could could buy tickets, but they set upstairs right, you know, it was a segregated audience
So they wouldn't appear before a segregated and that was a big big stink, you know work
That was a high point of the banana the TV show, you know, television was coming into its own
And we did things, you know, so we did things like that. I know we we get them to cancel
So, you know, we had a couple guys wouldn't can't you know
I remember we went after some pianist who's a foreign guy. I don't know what his name was
We got him in Kansas City, but we would call each hotel in case you have so-and-so registered, you know
If you have so-and-so registered, the final we got
The hotel where he was registered and we we call him, you know, and he wouldn't he wouldn't do anything
But the bonanza people did so
uh, and then we published it we had a
student voice was like a four-page
Newsletter
It came out
I don't know how awful it came out, but uh
And that was for uh for friends of snake. I mean, that was a big mailing. It was
you know and
We had this old address-a-graph machine use these
Mimeograph stencils, you know, you had a tight stencil. I was like typing our own Mimeograph
Stencil, I don't know if you remember that technology. We had a tight distencils and Mimeograph to press releases, you know, and a folder and
And call, you know stuff the envelope. We did all that stuff
But the student voice was an operation just to mail it because several thousand lists was always growing if you wanted to go
I was you know, you got it for free and uh, you know, it went mainly to northern friends of snake
You know people, you know
It's a way of keeping the movement informed
Kind of asking you just to describe the office
I wanted to ask you just to describe because you're talking about all this activity and I'm just it's just describe the office
It's self-physically and how many people were there and what it felt like could be a part of that
It was like uh
It was on three and a half hundred street
It was above a barber shop, you know, uh, we had one two three four
Seven rooms
With a hall and a middle
In the first room in the front of the building was a tiny uh
That's what Julian's office was
You know, uh, so we had three or four of us
With four type riders
you know
In those days, you know, that was the the introduction of IBM Selectric typewriter typewriter
I don't know if you we were working with manual type when I started we were working with manual type riders
Type of a memory of stencil with a man, you know, and pressing, you know, you uh
But then then we the selectric came in and you could
Fool with type faces because right you could change the balls, you know, uh, that was a big deal
That was a big deal, right? I was a major
Spruce it up, you know, uh, uh, you did the headline of one type one ball in the body, you know, and you could italicize
Yeah, the ball frightali, you know, it was so it was a tiny office
Four of his Bob Wald Mike Sair
myself Julian
You know in that office then it was a little room outside that office
And then the next room down was Dinky Romilly who was kind of (Jim) (Jim) Forman and secretary
And the back room was an even smaller room for where (Jim) (Jim) Forman and at his office
He was by and the other side
Was the bookkeeper in her office and then there was a larger room and then the front office was a Ruby Doris Smith Robinson
was her office. He was
kind of coordinating the campus
Field people
So we would we had the machine address of our machine and uh and the folding machine in a big room
You know, and so we did the voice
And then that we at one point we took the building next door
We had a guy come down that said uh, you know, uh, why why memory if we could offset the
AB dick and started to make desktop
Offset machines and they made a 360 which was like uh
It was a floor machine, but it was you know akin to a big memory of so his name was Mark Zuckle.
He came down and uh, we bought a uh an AB Dick
So the building next door we did our own printing
You know, eventually we went to the office that we gave up the memory, you know,
memory graft
You know thing and uh and so uh that was the facility and then there was a little room
Next to where we had the printing press where we stored
you know
Snickmade or uh record. I mean they
Freedom in the Air"" SNCC record" SNCC record, you know, we pressed the record Pete Seeger, you know
Got him to press a record they were gonna sell from as a fundraiser, but
It sat there the stacks of them sat piles of them sat there because
Think mercury signed them the group, you know to a contract, you know, there was a better deal
So that I have a copy somewhere. I don't know where it is that but that was destroyed that pressing that was done by
SNCC was kind of destroyed and then there were posters Danny Lyon
You know the photographer would do he saw a lot of the posters what air, you know and because they were
They were fundraising tool, you know, they were sold. I remember an album called
Freedom in the Air"" SNCC record that was on the SNCC record label. Well, that's it. Is that it? Okay. I've seen that yeah, and it had
Now it takes of Charles Sherrod
Wecturing and had Freedom in the Air"" SNCC record" SNCC record. There a lot of Southwest Georgia. Yeah. Well the group was way from you know
Bertha Gober and
Bernice Johnson Reagon and Cordell Reagon Reagon and
Original pre there was another woman Ruth-Etta Harris. Yeah, you know, she was still going strong right? Yeah, so
so they are
Yeah, so I think that that's the record that never got distributed, you know
There may be around somewhere and but because they sign you know mercury
I think was the label that put them out then they put out a couple records on mercury, you know
I think Pete Seeger recorded that
What was that that the record Freedom in the Air"" SNCC record? Well the (Guy + Candie) Carawan are part of it in alomex
Actually actually no that one was
That has a cover of
The praying before of a praying
Jacket the record jacket. Yeah, I think that is no that that's a second one notice one the one I'm talking
I never got Pete Seeger recorded it okay
It never got it when there was no jacket. Okay, they hadn't designed a jacket when they signed so it was like in in white
You know, right just in the sleeve CDs used to come to sleeves right yeah, that's
I may have a copy somewhere but uh
Well
I can say if you can find it I'm sure the library of congress would love to have a copy of that that's they may have a copy by miss about
I'm just saying
Maybe we can look after we finish that's great. So that's what I I kind of
Did when I got you know and I got there through that that year, you know, they're for a year
Well, no, I was I was there until that was 64 of 63
In the spring of 64 at the
the the the the big staff meeting
Ella Baker and Bob Moses came to me and asked if I would go to Washington to
work on the
Mrs. Beer Freedom Democratic
Party challenge
what it happened was is that the
summer project you know that that year was
was
summer project was hatched
You know and everything and
Moses had been in washing departed a summer project was to send to the
Did the Democratic National Convention Atlantic City in August of 64
An integrated delegation
in those years
From the southern states only white
You know delegations came to the Democratic Party National Convention
so
Part of a summer project was to
To organize a delegation under the rules of the Mississippi Democratic Party
You know to send an integrated delegation to Atlantic City
And so the idea was to mimic not you know to mirror the the the procedures
Now as to try and go to the Democratic Party meeting they would be expelled and they would hold their own meeting right
so in as I remember
There were like precinct meetings which will largely sometimes in people's homes businesses
There were counting meetings and then it was a state convention
So if they could find out where a precinct meeting was they would try and go to a precinct meeting
And they would get ex wouldn't be provided to go and say hold their own precinct meeting
Unlike delegates to go to the county meeting
They would try to go to the county meeting get turned away and hold their own county meeting and they held a state convention
So this was part of and you know the people that went
the
Freedom summer you know that was part of freedom schools
But the freedom Democratic Party and
and they had had some
Freedom vote you know
during that spring and
As a test I forget what the vote was over
To kind of they were trying to demonstrate that African Americans wanted a vote you know that it would vote
You know, I forget what the freedom vote was over. But anyway Moses was in Washington in February or any
Was speaking in a fundraiser and outlining what the the summer project was going to be and and when he talked about this
Uh
Challenge it to the Democratic National Convention a guy in the audience was named Joseph L. Rauh Jr
who was uh
If he wasn't headed the ADA
Americans for Democratic action. He was a prominent very prominent in it
He was a general counsel for the United Auto Workers. He was a D.C. attorney and he had been
Uh with human Hubert Humphrey and the delegation from D.C. in 1948
When they first raised the question of segregate you know and
Kind of that's Hubert Humphrey's signature, you know
Association with civil rights was that the fight at the 48th convention
So Rauh, you know publicly said if you bring a delegation, you know an integrated delegation from Mississippi
You know, we'll see that it gets seated or some you know
So that meant that uh, you know we had you know the
So the decision was made to open an office in in Washington in in spring
And Miss Baker and Moses asked me if I would go there and and staff and the idea was to uh
To try and commit
Northern state democratic party
delegations to support the seating of a
Of a rival delegation from Mississippi, you know an integrated
delegation of Mississippi
So uh
Mrs. Baker was in charge at the office
She had moved from Atlanta to New York, but you know she was we kept in touch with a telephone she came down
you know periodically and uh
And the guy named Frank Smith, you know he uh
He came up from uh Mississippi to work in the office and a woman named Barbara Jones from
She was part of some a project from uh, I think she was from Queens
You know she worked and we were the three of us and and uh
You know, we uh
We visited the
We attended state
Democratic party state conventions
We did mailings to delegates. We assembled a list as delegates were chosen. You know, we're on top of the process and uh, and
We visited
For instance, I remember Mrs. Baker and sister now we go see Adam Clayton Powell Jr
You know, she had known him from
Harlem in the 30s, you know, and uh
She told us you're not going to get anywhere, but we gotta go see him
So we all went to see Adam Clayton Powell Jr with her, you know, uh, she got to see appointment and yeah
And that's something so what kind of response did you know he came in oh Mrs. Baker how good this you know like a
But she was right. He didn't do anything
Now because I remember I saw him in Atlantic City, you know at the New York
delegation had a caucus meeting in the hotel what I was staying and
We were looking for help, you know at any way
Uh, he was tied to Lyndon Johnson, you know
But we did that sort of thing. So I went to
I think I attended the Minnesota
Wisconsin and Michigan
Convention state conventions say the Democratic
You know and uh, why be based in DC is that just for lobbying?
Well, yeah because the Democratic National Committee was there and the Democratic National Committee was organized and
The convention they just thought that I mean right
We thought that so they should be in in D.C. So I was we went to DC and I opened the office. It was on
14th in New Street, you know and uh and uh, you know
There were people like
Robert Kastenmeier was a congressman from Madison, Wisconsin. Yeah, he proved that to be very helpful and uh, how was that
Total aside, but what was that neighborhood like 14th and you and at that time? It was like the commercial
Strip of the African-American meeting now. It's I was there not too long ago hard to recognize
But it was like kind of a little bit seedy not really but you know like
Like a commercial stripping
That's the area that burned after King died I think
Maybe you know maybe but uh, and now it's a hipster area now. It's now it's not becoming an area
Booming air boom
That was our plan there was that was a plan and you know we were we were pretty good
I had as I said we had resolutions at it. He uh
Well Mondale was a power. Not Mondale had taken home free seats
You know in no Mondale was the attorney general of Minnesota. So he was the featured speaker at the Wisconsin
You know and I was and we had a table, you know at uh, you know, and there was a couple of students, you know from
Well, there was one student from Madison somebody had come over a boyfriend or something a friend that come over from Minnesota
He was a graduate student at you
University Minnesota, you know the man the table and I remember Mondale cautioned me about him, you know
It's too radical, you know
But the conventions were you know support of in those days, you know
All segregated delegation, you know, so we had resolutions that they would pass resolutions
Yeah, absolutely pass resolutions and you know
had Michigan
The power and the convention was a woman that
She was a repub- she was a Democratic National Committee woman
And she was an aide to Walter Reuther. She was kind of ran the convention and
Mildred Jeffrey was a name, you know, we got a
strong resolution out of Michigan, you know and
and
We had a guy a former congressman and Oregon was helping us, you know and
and uh the the the we were looking
Strategy was riled kind of new, you know, he wouldn't work directly with us, but he would work with
wouldn't uh with
With Bob Moses, you know, we actually went to New York. We talked Jim Forman and Bayard Rustin and
They, you know, I think buyer had been asked to do the job that that I got he didn't want to do
You know, so
But uh, but you talked to them for advice or yeah, we told we had a median in Bayard Rustin's's office, you know and
Bayard (Rustin) was there, Mrs. Baker was there, Frank Smith was there. I was there, you know and tell them what we're doing and
what the strategy was and and kind of the strategy was to
In order to get it onto the Florida Convention, you needed a minority report of the committee
Rules required that you had 10% of the of the delegates in a credentials committee sign a minority report
You know, and then
And then you had to have so many
delegations vote
you know
Okay, you know, so we were trying to get
Delegates as they were chosen to the credentials committee
And we were trying to get the delegations to agree that we would have a roll call vote
No, we're to get a to get a minority report
You needed a 10% of the delegates in a credentials committee
But to get a roll call vote on either the minority or a majority report
You know, you need to tend to delegate 10 delegations to vote the ass for it. Yeah, you know, so
So that was our strategy
I had to get a roll call vote because and we also want the minority because the minority report is voted on first
And if you had a roll call vote in a minority report, you know
We were in good shape
We thought so
And the credentials committee delegates were chosen differently, you know, somewhere
Some delegates some delegates that are convention was chosen in state party conventions
some were chosen in a in a balloting for the for the you know primary
So an argon for instance Wayne Morse was the leading
vote getter
And he had his choice under the rules argon he had his choice he wanted to be on the resolutions
You know because he was concerned about the war, you know, what I have
But so either green became she was a congresswoman
She became she took the position on a credentials committee
Okay, and she was a strong she stayed with us to the to the very end virtually. She was a she turned out to be a very strong
Supporter, you know because of Fannie Lou Hamer, you know testimony
Castamaya was on a credentials committee, you know
He we asked them, you know to get on you know, that was one of the things we didn't wash and then
Okay, you know, yeah, so we were interested in who's gonna be on a credentials committee and
Could we get the delegates of a state
contingent to vote to ask for a a a roll call votes
The planning of this operation is really
Impressive, but there's a lot that went into it. Well, yeah because at the same time, you know
We weren't involved although they were heading up towards a state convention miss Baker became
Dr. King when keynote the state convention, you know, I want you know in the middle of Mississippi summer
You know, so mr. Baker was the keynote. That's a famous speech that she made, you know
It's an important speech, but uh, you know, so we were using the parents of the kids in Mississippi. Mm-hmm
You know to pressure
You know
people, you know
It was all kind of what we were doing
Whatever the consistency was we were trying to involve them in
In this thing and at the same time, we had the freedom schools. We had the shorn
And then been chaining, you know thing doing so everything was was going on and
And we had to find housing for the delegates. That was our job, you know
We rented a hotel in Atlantic City
You know, yeah, Reggie Robinson came up, you know to help us
towards the end and we sent him to the Atlantic city found his small hotel 100 rooms
That they would rent the whole thing to us. So oh
So we had all had to do and
How many delegates? They were like sixty
You know, Ed King and Aaron Henry would have co-chaired Ed King was a
he was a
I think a full out
Theologic guy Reverend he was a Reverend but he taught at Tougaloo
College, yeah, and Aaron Henry was a president of state and the VACP
You know, and we had
Fannie Lou Hamer
Annie Devine and Victoria Gray the three
Grand women of
Mississippi movement
You know
And what was it like working with them?
Well, I didn't have much contact with them, you know
Same a little more than the other, you know, but they were in a delegation and I don't know if you want to
So we got to you know, we did what we could as I say I attended those three conventions. We were mailing the delegates
You know, we were we were dealing with parents
Trying to get parents involved with it, you know, the kids were in Mississippi in terms of pressuring, you know back home and
in Atlantic City
The credentials committee the convention opened on Monday night and so the committees met
You know before the convention and
The credentials committee met on Saturday and Sunday and
Lyndon Johnson was
Presumed nominee. There was you know, there was no
Nothing going to happen at the convention, you know other than who was going to be the vice president
Right. That was the only question. So there was no news
You know, so this challenge
And it became news because they had a hearing and it was televised
You know, there was a kind of a slow, you know
and
Fannie Lou Hamer just had a lot of the women on you know the credentials committee was half man, man half women that was a way was so
She told about being beaten and jailed and were known in Mississippi and you know, she had after the women they crying, you know, Johnson broken
you know
broken to the TV by calling a press you know, he went into the press room and in the white house, you know
And of course they cut away he had nothing I don't know what he would talk about nothing, but you know they cut away from
Yeah, yeah, cut the TV away. It was kind of an early early
indication how powerful TV was but Mrs. Green was moved by that you know, so that kind of a put her
You know in our camp so we needed like
I think
10 to 10 like 11 signers on a report, you know the binary report and I don't know if you want to go in all the
the
machinations of
What happened
Well
Let's see
So you know the delegates the delegates had come up, you know integrated it wasn't
Well integrated, but it was integrated you know there were two or three whites and delegation the
Mississippians they sent what we called a no-name delegation
Because they didn't want anybody he slend or (James) Eastland + (John) Stennis + Governor (Ross) Barnett or the governor rose, you know to be in the dollar when they would normally
Right being the delegation, but they sent absolutely, you know, nobody's you know
uh
And what was the reason for them not to put well because the you know if you put Eastlinder, you know,
Rospa on edit the chairman of the delegate it's gonna draw you know attention
You know that they just did not listen strategy not not to draw attention to it
You know you had these two rival delegations claiming the seats, you know, and uh and you had the (Barry) Goldwater
Everybody was worried about gold. What it was gonna nuke, you know, and uh
You know, what have you and uh
So Mrs. Green strategy was to give a loyalty oath to everybody
If you wouldn't sign a loyalty oath
You know, you couldn't be a delegate, okay, you know, no what happened was actually the the
The the the white delegation they went back and they they worked for (Barry) Goldwater, you know
Goldwater Carrier Mississippi in 64. So it was kind of
You know looking back on it
You know, yeah fool because they had no intention of supporting Johnson and hopefully you know, they you know, whatever you but uh
So they had the hearing and you know and they we had a brief row wrote a brief, you know about the legal brief
You know, and we had five thousand copies pretty we everybody got a copy of the credentials committee the the
Mississippians they wouldn't distribute their brief, you know
Had a brief and uh, you know, they very very said very much, you know, they were counting on Johnson, you know, and I'm free
So as I say the the initial response was all in favor of of uh, you know of
Of freedom Democrats, you know, to seek the freedom Democrats and of course delegates, you know, you can imagine
All the northern west and nobody, you know, at that time
Everybody was against segregation and whatever you but you know
Hubert Humphrey and Reuther came to town, you know, and started twisting arms and uh and uh
So did the individual delegates from other states reach out to you? Do you remember that level of support?
Oh, we had a lot of support. We had it there was a 20 like it was a 24-hour vigil on the boardwalk
Okay delegates were coming yeah, and the delegates gave us their badges
So you couldn't get into the hall without a delegates or observe a badge and what happened was is that
The Mississippians went home the whites went home
You know
After a hearing, you know, they didn't state it sort of seats were empty
You know, and then when the final the the final front was that the the freedom Democrats could get to
Yeah seats in the balcony
As observers as observers and they wanted to pick Ed King and Aaron Henry, you know
As the you're not not even let the delegates choose who they would
So they got they had a sit-in and in the seats the they got delegates to give up their
Their badges so they could get into the hall and you know, that's that's then rather got roughed up. You know, I mean that's a famous kind of footage there
Uh
So yeah the delegates were supportive
But it was a controlled situation by Johnson. Oh, well, he wasn't there at a white house
You know using Hubert Humphrey and Ruther Hubert Humphrey was
Was held down dangle as his nomination was in jeopardy if if this didn't get the you know, if the South Bolton
You know, that sort of thing and and so they twisted arms and
meetings, you know
And they had the timing you know, they had the
They dropped the compromise what what was the so-called compromise at the last minute, you know, and then they spread the word
You know that they had been accepted
You know, I think
Maybe Henry and the king in a meeting and Ed King not even Dr. King accepted it
But you know in a meeting with Reuther and I said they would accept it
So the word went out so the kind of the steam went out of the delegates hard before the delegates
We were at a loss in terms of communication, you know with the broad, you know, delegate, you know, we didn't have any operation that
Can you describe the compromise?
The compromise was that the freedom Democrats would get
Two seats as observers in a balcony. They would be Ed King and you know Aaron Henry
and there would be something about
The 72 convention this was no the 68 convention
Actually if you remember in 68 Julian
Was you know delegate from joy, you know in Chicago, you know, I mean, that was the result of of the Ruckus in
64 you know, they would look at the rules or what have you so
It kind of ended all white
delegations to the Democratic National Convention, but
There was a it was a major
Rubicon for the movement especially the snake movement in sick people in terms of trying to force the delegation to accept
That that compromise, you know, they wanted the delegation to
To vote to accept that delegation that compromise and they wouldn't do it, you know, so we had a meeting
In the church that morning and we had all illuminaries
Of the civil rights movement most of them came
To kind of convince the delegates to accept it baird and Dr. King and
Jack Pratt of the National Council of Churches and James Farmer and you know Wayne Morse
you know
They all had their argument, you know, what have you and
some of the snake people got their kind of first taste of
of democratic
party
politics, you know in terms of
when you when you kind of rub up against
you know
The essence of the democratic party that you know what the resistance is, you know kind of so
So what were some of the arguments coming from these luminaries to accept that compromise?
Well, Wayne Morse's argument I think was
was gold water
You know if we don't do this if we forced them to to walk out the other, you know, to help gold water, okay
You could say that was an honest I mean it was an honest concern in retrospect
You know when you look at the results of the election
It was you know Johnson whatever what a lance, you know, right, you know kind of now looking back at the whole thing
You know and Johnson didn't carry those he won the popular vote in the landslide
He didn't carry the southern states anyway, so you know if they had forced them out
Really would have you know, but that was the argument
others argued, you know, this is a great deal, you know, and
We shouldn't do a look at gift-toss in a mouth, you know, and that sort of thing and
So you know people kind of were front, you know young young stick people were kind of a front and everybody was there
You know, I mean and even a lot of the
Summer volunteers, you know, it come come there, you know from this was the end of the end of the summer for them
So there's a lot of right well, so if you had worked on a on a freedom Democratic party
As I say to precinct county in the state convention state convention was a big deal and
In Mississippi and at that summer, you know because it was
Chance everybody to get together, you know, they had delegates from all
all the
The county all the the delta counties that Lee, you know, I mean
Miss Baker was a you know was it was what they were trying to
Who ply, you know kind of making like a like a state convention
So it was so a lot of the volunteers had worked either on freedom schools
I helped this whatever you did, you know, you knew what was going on with the freedom Democratic party convention
You know the landage city government so a lot of a lot of youngsters went back
But a lot of kids came to Atlantic City on their own, you know, and they saw so a lot of energy there
Yeah, and they saw the comp, you know, mean they saw the attempt to force the compromise
you know
Down their throats and so it led to a lot of disillusionment, you know kind of and uh and
It led this is you know to kind of redbaiting, you know, there was a famous Rowland Evans + Robert Novak article that appeared
shortly thereafter, you know
kind of
Redbaiting the snake, you know because uh of this you know, it was a threat to the Democrat
They didn't put it as a threat to the Democratic party, but
clearly it you know
It was a they saw it as a threat to the Democratic party and you know uncompromising so
That kind of opened up a can of war, you know with the redbaiting, you know Rowland Evans + Robert Novak they were
Novak was a redbait, you know kind of thing, but
That was a syndicated column at the time, you know a lot of a lot of
So that was you know
That challenge led to the the challenge in
in
65 of the seeding of the three
congressional
Democrats from the Mississippi Delta
Jamie Whitten and two others, you know, they actually
Uh
They were actually forced to stand aside
I didn't work on it. I mean, I was tangentially connected to it, but they uh I went back to Washington and
we
wrapped it up the you know, whatever we had to do and and
The people that worked on the congressional challenge
They took over from there to a lot of lawyer canoey consul
You know miss Baylor, it was a bomb, John Conyers, Elizabeth Holtzman
You know, they actually got the house to
The force to three one, you know, the house is sworn in at the first day of the new session
So if you oppose if you object to somebody being sworn in
They can't take the oath
So they they uh they objected to the three of them on a basis that
It was unrepresented, you know, that uh and so uh tip on Neil that didn't want to do it, but he forced them to stand aside
They were kind of
Incomments so they continued to do what they were doing, but they
Hadn't actually been sworn in and there was a commission or a hearing, you know, they actually got a chance to have some hearing so the congressional challenge
You know had some substance to it and uh it took a while for it to play out into the next spring before they were finally
Resolved and they were sworn, you know, not that they weren't functioning as kind they weren't voting, but they were functioning as
Staff and office, you know, that sort of thing right yeah, I was gonna ask if there was could you talk about disillusionment
But I also imagine that there's some momentum coming out of the MFDP fight. So this is one
Think or where there are other ways in which
Sort of the the getting stirred up played out
Well, I think people turn their attention down a bama, you know, I'd say to
You know, it wasn't I think it was more disillusioning than energize it. Okay. I'd say you know, historians may
may
You know, you had the beginnings of kind of bickering, you know
You know
Built into the situation those that kind of
Close to the
Democratic party
Yeah, you know, those are you know kind of uh and uh, you know
People kind of gave up. I mean if you saw this the demo, you know, what have you?
You know, you kind of went off you had black power, you know kind of kind of beginning
So you see that as a as kind of a I don't know whether it's starkly valid, but I'd say you know, it's it's uh with the red baiting and
You know, what have you it's a
It's uh, it's something to think about you have to look at it more
History of it, but the the year after the challenge in Mississippi kept you know, the congressional challenge kept on and
And what have you
Moses let you know
Moses left it was an attention turned down a bama, you know
Stokely Carmichael in Lowndes County and in the next year, you know kind of right 60
That must have been 64 65, you know and uh and uh
So it was a turning point, so fracture it was yeah, you know because uh
You know, you look back at it from this vantage point and you say my goodness, you know
What what tragedy would have been created you know found some some formula, you know if you if you had the
The white delegation under your thumb which they did you know by a lot. They could have found some
You know, that would have you know
They could have found some
Kind of weighted enough to see them in the same area. They could have you know, they could have found
Uh
The kind of forced this and and they really had a force it down and you get
If you look at the Taylor Branch's book. I think he has it, you know
I think I gave an interview to Anne Romaine
About some of the machinations, but you know the uh, I was in a room with King
You know a bunch of us were in a room and at a hotel in in his hotel room, you know
At the time, you know, but the underhand in this, you know and the arm twisting
Rao
Who said I'll be with you and nobody's with you
You know that's almost a direct political album with you and you know
Push came to shove. He said I can't sign that you know Ruth to told him forget
You made so much from the you know you ate it last year, you know, you won't get a penny, you know
And some woman
An African-American woman a husband was up for a judgishhip in California. She you know
Right. They told her forget about it and uh, you know
So when they put the heat on you know
The only people that stood were cast a mire and uh and he just green
Everybody else, you know
They couldn't sign it
That's pretty eye-opening, too
Well, I mean that wasn't generally known, but I mean, you know that was the kind of pressure
that was put on
On the uh on the on the the credentials committee people who were regular people who some of which we didn't know
You know and and what have you the the pressure put on the delegates the the (Mississippi) Freedom Democratic Party delegates and the Vagratic body delegates
To accept the compromise
You know what have you was equally is you know as I say every
What I don't know of Roy Wilkins came was there at that meeting. You know, or is but every
significant person in the sorority that had been involved with mr. B. Summer
Yeah, you know was came to to argue for that
to that for that
Compromise, you know
Kind of thing and uh, yeah, and as they say more as you could say well, he believed it
That go you know mean
So there was some uh
Some element of sincerity, you know kind of uh, but the others, you know
There's a problem, you know, they were they they knew home free, you know, they knew Ruthie, you know
Johnson, you know, what have you and they knew more than we knew it to tie, you know, what the other side was saying and doing you know
Because they were you know confident. So
So that was more of disillusioning I'd say, you know in terms of
What could be achieved
Yeah, just
Really amazing strike and what about your your personal journey from from there
Well, I went back to Atlanta, you know
Well, let me before you say that it just
For you personally and for those in the office. What was the mood after afterwards?
I mean you talked about disillusionment, but can you tell a little bit more of
Well, you know you've been working on this for close to a year probably no, I was just working on it from from
May or April, May to August. Oh, that's okay. You know, that was that all over that we we you know with it
Even in the in Mississippi. I mean the precinct meetings didn't start until that summer. You know, I mean
They were you know, you were getting a delegation
You know democratic party
Has its own rule, you know, I mean each state has its own rules. So not a so we we work on it was like a three or four months more project, you know and
You know depending on how into you into what you were and democratic what you thought you know, I mean
I wasn't too into the democratic party. So, you know, it's kind of the the the red baiting thing the Rowland Evans + Robert Novak thing kind of indicated
that there was more common, you know and uh and
You know, it was a more it was a bigger thing and uh
But Frank Smith he stayed in Washington and became
He was elected to city council. I think he heads a non-profit now, you know, he became a prominent in in Washington, you know
Barbara Jones. I think she must have gone back
You know to New York City. I met her at some function for alabaker and I don't know what
What she was doing, you know, what she ended up eventually doing and
Miss Baker went to back Reggie Robinson went on, you know, I mean so it was like
It was expect, you know, you kind of expected it, you know, I mean, I think most when people thought about it
they kind of uh, you know
Well, it wasn't unexpected, you know, I mean uh that they would uh and do you know do this, you know
Put the clamp clamp on it. It's kind of like a political campaign. It's not an act and you know
Yeah, right and any other thing is that uh
You know, you're kind of proud of the the rank of foul freedom democrats that they stood up to it and they voted
You know, it didn't make you know, there was no big deal for Aaron Henry and Ed King
It was a big deal to be recognized by you know the power, you know, Johnson and you know, what have you but
And I imagine seeing the support from delegates from other states
For Hartman Turnbow and Mrs. Devine and Fannie Lehamer and
You know, it wasn't uh, it wasn't a big deal
You know, what I mean?
The rank of file delegates that have been elected that a lot of them were
Freedom fighters, you know, in their own little community, you know, what have you they got
Amzie Moore or Amzie Moore, if I don't remember if he was a delegate or not, but uh
But you even get to go
Well, I did go, but I'm just saying they stood up. They understood, you know that it wasn't
You know two seats in mean it, you know, I mean they kind of saw the compromises
It wasn't
You know anything, you know, it was it wasn't related to the real issues
So they they so you kind of had to take heart that they're understanding, you know, was that good that
they didn't fall for it, you know and and
and
Liftoff would go on to the next so that was kind of what we
What we thought oh, no, I don't think we ever had a meeting, you know, afterwards
We all we all kind of Amzie Moore, you went out to the next thing. That was the movement days
You know, you want out to the next next next big thing or the next small thing the next thing that you were interested in and
so
And that all our time is in the ran and look here wounds the people that were interested in the freedom Democrats in in
Mississippi Lawrence Guyot
You know and they went back. Yeah, I mean they tried to you know work with the freedom
You know, I mean they had the electro ambitions and you know, they they paid attention to it
but for us it was just the
the convention challenge
you know and
and move on you know
there were a lot of as I say the
Shorin a goodman cheney, you know, murders in the freedom schools and
You know, what's the name? Didn't Jane Jane Stembridge get into valve with some of the curriculum, you know
You know, so people were on to other things, you know, and as I said, they moved on and
there was kind of
There was kind of a feel. I mean, it was kind of a consensus. You'd say that it was a good thing that the compromise wasn't accepted
Democrats who were who they would you know turn out to be and yeah, you know, but as I say people moved on
That was that was the times, you know, I mean it didn't
Unless you were involved in it, you know, had some
You know connection to it or some outlook for like Giat, you know, you did something else
And so what did have I for you?
I went back and I got involved in trying to
To work with the labor movement or encourage the labor movement to get involved with the
with
Civil rights and try to stimulate some organizing
in the south and
I organized one or two workshops. I forget at Highlander, you know, where we had some
Northern labor people and some, you know
What I think actually first
Actually, this may have been before I was involved with Carl Braden and
and Jim Williams in trying to found a white student organization the white southern student
Which eventually became
so
SNCC kind of put up Carl Braden's contact list and SNCC kind of
agreed to a former agreed to let me send out a letter or you know, one that we had a meeting in Nashville with Suhthrasher
I think and that went on on their own, you know, to become
SOC, student organizing committee and and was snick actively supporting this idea at that point of
They had
Well, they had originally Zellner you know, Bob Zelner and Jane Stembridge and
and at that time it was a guy Sam Shirah, you know, came on board
was kind of sort of a traveling white campuses and
and sort of an increasing number of white southerners and
and even some northern is that that's kind of sort of potential
You know the labor movement in terms of its money and and cloud. So I organized as I say one or two
You know
workshops at high on the
you know, we had
Jesse Prosten from the
Packinghouse workers they were the amalgamated meet cutters at the time they had merged the packenhouse workers was a
one of the left wing CIO unions
He had been active, you know, when as I say in that tent city
Committee in Chicago
Bob Lewis, I think was
Came down he was a general counsel for the United Electrical Workers
There was some
Teams to guy from Tony Zivolich
from Atlanta. He was a
Business agent and big teams to local in Atlanta
Maybe some guys from the clothing work as ILGWU
ILGWU yeah, the ILGWU ILGWU
So you know there were a
Lot of not a lot, but a number of white
You know and some some black I think James Orange ended up, you know
in a relationship with a union and that actually went to work
you know
so
So it's the end of
into 65, you know, and I
I left
I went to work for the UE
You know and not in the south because they didn't have any membership in the south
Actually K and I we had met at Highland there and
We met that's we met at Highland here one of those workshops, you know
And just for the record can you
Tell the people out there who K is and
And
He remarried since 1967 so long long long time she
Kay Marlowe
she was
She had come to south
To one of her freedom
Freedom Vote and had his Bergmississippi with the
With the University of Illinois and the NAACP chapter
They had done some work in the Cairo, Illinois. That's a famous, you know and
so
I don't know how she got to Highland that we met at Highlander and she yeah she had worked in
The (Anne and Carl) Bradens got her involved in not the Bradens. actually she got involved in
Committing for minors. It's called a committee for minors. It was a it was a Wildcat strike movement in eastern Kentucky
led by
UMWA guy named Berman Gibson and
and
In typical East to Kentucky fair, you know
Guys were charged with blowing up a bridge that was still standing
Conspiracy to blow you know, so it had been a Paul O'Dwyer
He was kind of a labor attorney city councilman and uh Paul O'Dwyer
Yeah, he was a progressive genuine progressive guy. He was the brother of a not so progressive mayor of
New York City
but
Stanley Aronowitz
Paul O'Dwyer and another guy whose name
He had a funny name
Irish name they formed a
Support committee for his rank of file movement in eastern Kentucky and they hired K to go there to work with the
with that movement and she went there and
She produced a it's unfortunate. I would have probably the Braden papers have copies of
She produced a news on Mimigaw have news that I go minus for justice kind of
It's a record of so she was working in eastern Kentucky when we had this workshop and they got wind of it
And so she came that's how we met she was working, you know in eastern Kentucky
so
we went we left
uh
We both went to work for you. We she she was went to work as a colonizer
In uh, how tuna Pennsylvania and Slovenian
She tried to get it and they sent me to Lynchburg, Virginia to try and get into a general electric plant
I got to observe a
Prairie prominent trial of a youngster
Whose name slept he was a rape case
We in William Kunstler and Phillip J. Hirschkop for the attorneys
Some elderly woman had been raped
The police and all she could tell the police were uh that the guy had big ears
So the police rounded up everybody in Lynchburg that had big ears and this youngster had a
An alibi that you know was less than solid so he was the one who was charged and uh
The rapist that approached it from behind and knocked off our glasses. So
You know Hirschgaugh had to uh, William Kunstler was sort of like the
The public face of the trial and uh Hirschgaugh had the
Difficult task of cross-examining her, you know on her
You know, but that came out in uh
In pre-trial, you know
That the the publisher of (Lynchburg, VA) newspaper
And instructed the the editor they had a sentence
William William Kunstler, you know, radical civil rights lawyer from New York City something like that, you know
There was a standard sentence that he had to drop in every every story
The first time you mentioned William Kunstler and he mentioned William Kunstler and every story, you know
I noticed that
just parenthetically that uh
the chariot
Newspapers apologize to uh for its
It's a characterization of Local 22
It was a left-led union to try to organize tobacco workers in in North Carolina. They so
Lynchburg, you know, newspaper needs to apologize
But it is I don't know I forget what his name was
He was eventually acquitted. I mean, they it wasn't acquitted was convicted
But they it was eventually overturned and he never he never went to jail
But so I got to observe
That the that trial there in Lynchburg, but I never got into the plant
Eventually uh, which plant again?
What which plants? General Electric kind of non-union plant there in Lynchburg. Okay. So
So K didn't get into the plant and out too, I think
But they had an election they lost the election, you know, and uh
They moved to the Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office because that's what the Pittsburgh PA UE district office was and uh
She kind of decided to uh
To uh
Finish she found out that she could finish her her BA at the University of Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office
so I was
commute I was working in Detroit
You know and uh
Fiti UE and go back a week and so so venture we decided get married and I moved back to Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office and
We spent about 20 years
We're gonna in Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office
And continuing to do this kind of work for yeah, we got involved in the uh actually we got involved before and the anti-bioting and war
movement, you know the people's assembly Moses and the stonlin and
Howard's it, you know, what have you were there was famous
Washington
peace demonstrations in the spring of 65
You know that we were involved in and then uh
We got back to uh
The Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office, you know, we there was big big anti-war movement
All over the place committee to actually the committee got into war of yet name the national or I think they had a conference
They may have been founded at a conference in Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office that we helped organize, you know, but uh
Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office had a big big anti-war
You know movement and uh
So you got involved in that what were you doing to support yourself?
Well, I was like
Uh
I went when I left the UE we both left together, you know, uh pretty much so
Okay
We were living on on case subsidy from a family to go to school, you know
My family, you know contributed. I was work working uh
Uh
I worked we had a little piece of freedom center in Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office
I went to work for the hospital workers union in 1199 SEIU in New York City. They were
At that time thinking about expanding they had organized in Johns Hopkins and they were
Talking about Charleston. They had a campaign in Charleston, West Virginia. Yeah, it wasn't as successful
But the one at Hopkins so I knew a guy that was working as a
You know
How's keeping aid in uh in a hospital and he was interested so we we hooked up with 1199 SEIU and they put me on a staff
You know to work
Uh try it at then uh
Eventually K was also hired the two of us were hired and uh and she stayed, you know at some point they came to us
I said we can't
We don't believe in men and Amzie Moore kind of
couples on the you know so case stayed and she she organized uh
Pennsylvania in 1969 passed the public employee
bargaining law which included
Community hospitals non-profit, you know community hospitals under the under the axi
You could you could get an election you could get recognition, you know
Via state labor board, you know and it was before the national board, you know did it so
Uh she organized quite a few of Jewish
Jewish home and hospital
Scranton, you know
Lewis town, Washington she organized
quite a few, uh, you know workers there and I uh
I went to work for the Communist Party
You know unpaid because you know we had the one salary and I and we
joined the party and uh
After the (George) McGovern (1972) presidential campaign
And work and work
Yeah, I was I kind of was a kind of worked you know unpaid one you know from then on you know uh
till uh
Till we left you know Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office and when we left I worked and I ran the print shop with a
The newspaper of people's weekly world was printed you know
uh
From 1990 to 1995
Plant was in Camden, New Jersey
Okay
So I was you know I may have had uh, I did a stint with the amalgamated clothing workers union
You know I did a stint with the uh with the NEA affiliate and it was trying to organize university Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office faculty
You know PSEA, Pennsylvania State Education Association
uh
But basically I was you know they were short
Actually got canned by the Amalgamated when they found out I was I was a member of the party, but uh, I was gonna ask
Yeah, you know
Well, I I was fire. I was at I got a job at US Steel
You know, and it was got canned you know
because of uh of that so
So you know it uh
K's worked you know decent job so we've kind of made it on her one income for uh, you know
What
And what other
What other issues or interests have you had? I know we were talking sort of off camera about
The movements are all related and and you talked a little bit civil rights movement to the anti-war movement labor movement
Uh, any other big issues for for you or um campaigns or involvement
now
Yeah, or over yeah at various times. Well, you know, yeah
We were involved in uh in 1968 to try and get King Spock
To run for president vice president, you know uh
Uh
Actually, we petitioned uh at that time was terrible Pennsylvania had
Huge numbers signatures. You had to get him in a win. We the (MLK) King-(Benjamin) Spock ticket, you know, but they wouldn't you know
So it was Dick Gregory. We got Dick Gregory + Mark Lane on a ballot in Pennsylvania. Okay. It was Peace and Freedom Party
You know some some but there was a big you know new politics conference in 67 60. Yeah, you know
where that was put forward and uh and uh
That was a memorable
Cole- Cole effort, but uh Gregory was a good
Good candidate he came campaign for us a couple of times and and he had that one dollar bill with his picture on it
That was best campaign literature ever, you know secret service seized from us, you know, but uh
uh
And some you know, and they got involved in a party. It was involved with with some party, you know initiated stuff
Around a short of work week. It was a bill that Conyers had in 1978
To reduce the men to fail able to stand as act to reduce the
eight-hour date to seven and six hours
To raise the overtime penalty to double time and a half
And uh band compulsory overtime as a way of
stimulating employment at that time was a recession, you know
We involved in anti-Ragan efforts, you know and uh and what have you and uh
So one thing one thing or another cute pro Cuba solidarity work we were involved in you know and uh
In some of the other chili, you know the time at a coup and chili
We were uh, we had a big big effort in Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office. Yes, you know, we had Central America
Yeah Latin America is something more than I'll sell with a Nicaragua, you know, but chili was in 73, you know the coups in 73 and uh
we actually had a guy in
Friend of ours in Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office that had married a Chilean woman
He had been in Chile and uh
She had half a family with communists and other half for reactionaries. So the communists got them out of the country, you know, and he came to Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office and
Somebody got him a job in a in Westinghouse electric as a machinist
So you know, we had a big movement against Augusto Pinochet at the time in 1973 and
You know all the war, you know, the and goal of the wars in Africa, you know
Kind of but they were big ideological battles in the movement, you know at the time
You know whether Salvador Allende did the right thing or did you know what have you whether you know the Soviet and golands Amzie Moore
They're all big humans so forth. So, you know, we kind of that's what we've been doing and uh
So when I went to
1990 to
Managed a plant that produced a paper
I've in logic spent my time, you know kind of making that a profitable
operation, you know
Which we were able to do, you know, so now it's gone, but uh, I spent 15 years, you know 1990, 1995
K was here, you know, by
1990 I'm in 1990 to 2005
Actually we left the Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office in 1990
But Kay got a job here with the organizing nurses in
Paducah. she started with a campaign in Paducah at
(likely) Lourdes Hospital, Paducah KY and then
She moved here because they tried to organize hot nurses here in Louisville, Audubon Hospital and some other house
So I we she she commuted to New York or I commuted here, right and then uh
That went on for like 15 years
And then 2005 I retired and I moved here
So
She's born in Kentucky she was born in the right so it's coming back. Yeah, a family was grew she grew up in right across the river in Metropolis, Illinois
So anoy
so
You know her mother who just died a year ago, right, lives to be about 101 102 and this is so we were stayed here because Kay was the closest
Yeah, you know, and of course, this is this is Braden territory. So yeah, connection. I was right there. Yeah
So
Well, we hadn't too much
Contact with the Bradens. over the years we had contact with them, you know, we had aunt speaking Pittsburgh PA UE Pittsburgh PA UE district office once you know
I mean Carl died, you know, and you know, what have you but uh
Yeah, they were
No, it was largely because of
Kay developed some roots here on this organizing and her mother, you know
She was the closest daughter, so we had a responsibility
Well, we've covered a lot of great grind. Do you have any questions you want to ask?
And is there anything that I didn't ask about that you I should have asked about or anything else that you want would like to
I don't uh if you don't ask
You know what's relevant. I mean you kind of an idea what you what's relevant and uh well you know that you know the history
Well, you know, you could you could give you more like terms of the freedom challenge, but I think
That that history has been written about you know
Some but this was really because this is really great to get that yeah, well, I think the inside
You know what I but uh as I say my interpretation is my my interpretation as I say it
It could be challenged. I could be off, but seems to me that people came up against
The Democratic Party some illusions were stripped away at that moment, you know
and
You know, they've been recreated quite honestly, you know, right, you know
But they're being stripped away now. I mean you have some of the thing with Obama, you know kind of illusions and
And you know after five or six seven years, you know people kind of
uh, but
That was a moment, you know in time and
and when you look back at as I say how
ridiculous
The issue Amzie Moore it looks like in in retrospect, you know
It's not even segregate you know you could say segregation was ridiculous, you know, but it's kind of assist, you know, but yeah, you know
This was the kind of thing that
But as I say it was politics, you know, they could not they had some
commitments
I'd say you know it kind of played itself out in uh in terms of
Did you sort with judgeships if you looked at the eyes our pointies
They were the civil rights judges
(Judge) Minor Wisdom and
You know in New Orleans Elbert Tuttle chief judge of the fifth circuit
Judge Frank Johnson Jr, you know in Alabama
they were the
the
Titans of
Saved the system, you know judicially, you know with a fifth circuit at that time
Kennedy's appointees they were all
You know (James) Eastland + (John) (James) Eastland + (John) Stennis + Governor (Ross) Barnett + Governor (Ross) Barnett approved they were terrible
You know you have some
Some judge in one case telling a lawyer keep those picking innings, you know from jumping, you know and you know right in court and
You know Amzie Moore
The if it hadn't been for eyes and hours appointees system would have been in big trouble. They were the ones that
It saved, you know the big rulings that the
you know
That saved the kind of
Confidence in a system that the system could change, you know and whatever you think
So there was no Republican party in the South
Well if there was it was African-American so eyes and hours didn't have to clear
Judicial appointees with you know the
(James) Eastland + (John) (James) Eastland + (John) Stennis + Governor (Ross) Barnett + Governor (Ross) Barnett, you know, we could make them, you know kind of and
So you had these really fine jurists, you know appointed, you know and
And as I say one way or the other they saved that they hadn't been for the fifth circuit
System would have been in big big big big trouble, you know
Well the Supreme Guard, but you know
Johnson's a poor what's his name? Who's the guy that was forced out?
You know the guy that got him on us that got Johnson elected the first time
You know that they forced out. Yeah, but they weren't eyes and hours, you know, but uh
You know Felix Frankfurter and and (William O.) Douglas they weren't Eisenhower appointees
but what are you Eisenhower appointees? I don't think they were
Yeah, who is the Chief Justice?
Warren, Warren
You know
But as I say the same kind of a you know kind of a situation, but you know
You don't think about on the on the local level, you know on a day-to-day basis without without those judges, you know
uh
And aggressive lawyers, you know the lawyers guild and they were willing to you know use it they
You would have been in big big trouble and eventually the
You know the the court you know stepped in in terms of the all white delegate, you know you couldn't all white prime
You know what have you so
Now there's some really interesting history there. We're just talking about there with these local lawyers
Heroes at the local level all over the place. Yes Smith and Walts are in New Orleans, you know Ben Smith and Bruce Walts are and uh and uh
you know
Len Holt
you know and
uh
Some lawyers in the north that you know
(Ernest) Goodman + (George) Crockett and uh and
A lot of people you know
Canoi console, you know they were they were all
There was like a split you know the more conservative and that the more liberal lawyers and a more radical lawyers
You know kind of you had you had that split in in in the room, you know kind of
You had the split in terms of the congressional challenge, you know, what are you gonna
Force these guys out, you know, uh, or whether you're gonna compromise, you know and uh and uh kind of thing and so
Chilling effect, you know that was canoes
You know, but they had to get a judge to accept that you know mean
You know eventually the court accepted it, but you had to first get a district court judge to accept it
I think it was (Judge) Minor Wisdom
You know that accepted so
You know if it hadn't been for the left, you know kind of
SCEF you know the (Anne and Carl) Bradens and
People that
Virginia Durr but miss Baker, you know these kind of people that had principles, you know that weren't
Compromises, you know, they may not have been radicals, you know
But they just weren't compromised. They believed in kind of basic long, you know
That
Would have been a bad trouble
So that's what you had, you know, you had some illusions about the Democrats when I grew up as a kid
You know this question about uh
Oh, if only we could you know
African-Americans can vote, you know, we wouldn't have dixie crats, you know
So if you had if you could do it with the Dixie crew you get African-Americans to vote you could do a Dixie crats
You know it'd be a better system. Well, he was an opportunity to do it with the Dixie crats
Yeah, you know turned out they really didn't do it
Want to do it, you know, a roother and an unfried-headed railed against Dixie crats when when they had an opportunity, you know
They were bigger fish to fry, so
It's uh, it's instructive, you know
Well great
Thank you so much. This was really terrific and thank you so much for your time and for all of your work
Okay
I mean you're doing a good thing. I hope you get some funding. Hope it's there. Yeah, well, I think we're gonna cut you the pieces
Yeah, I think we're doing we're doing okay
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture